alors quand on est un groupe indépendant
comme le nôtre la liberté c'est avant
tout sa capacité à gagner de l'argent
c'est peut-être triste mais mais c'est
comme ça et donc l'aspect économique et
financier et est extrêmement important
et pourtant dieu sait que lui n'était
pas financier c'était un ingénieur à la
base et ils avaient des visions
stratégiques
il en a réussi énormément il en arrive
en art et en arrêter d'autres bien
évidemment comme tout le monde mais dieu
sait que ça n'était pas un financier pur
jus mais il savait il comprenait que
c'était un passage obligé
et donc à partir de là nous allons nous
semble retrouver quand même à la tête
d'un conglomérat et je voulais dis en
toute sincérité
nous n'avions vraiment pas les moyens de
développer tout ça est la création d'
eads la création d' eads c'était déjà sa
sortie par le haut puisque nous n'étions
plus maîtres de notre destin que nous le
partageons avec l'état français ce qui
était évidemment quelque chose
extrêmement flatteur mais aussi avec
d'autres actionnaires de nos amis
allemands de daimler à l'époque donc
déjà à cette époque on savait que ce
groupe ne pourrait pas résister aux
immenses besoins d'investissements que
nécessitait toutes ses activités et donc
petit à petit j'en reviens donc à ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on a dû
j'ai dû et ce qui m'a valu d'ailleurs
tous et toutes ses félicitations de
rétrécissement du groupe mais ça c'est
pas important je me suis dit ce groupe
ne survivra pas s'il est comme ça il
doit donc pour devenir plus grands
passer par une phase où il sera plus
petit et je me suis dit devant lui pas
ces derniers jours mais enfin disons
durant ces derniers mois
que franchement être le leader mondial
du livre pardonnez moi cette expression
ça a de la gueule et évidemment il a
adhéré à ces stratégies parce que
c'était sa passion
et donc de fil en aiguille après on a
développé un petit peu tout ça alors
europe 1 qu'est-ce qu'on comment puis-je
vous le dire repas il y était depuis 74
il a digéré dirait diriger il a été dans
les dents dans ses bureaux le vendredi
j'allais me retrouver dans les bureaux
ouverts tout ça on est quand même très
très loin des des vraies ambitions
économiques et financières d'un groupe
oui mais comme l'a dit très justement un
moment martin bouygues lorsqu'il a voulu
conserver bouygues telecom il n'y a pas
non plus que l'argent il y à 7,7 petit
comment dirais-je
sentimentalité autour de cette maison
europe 1 qui fait qu'on l'a tout de
suite sanctuariser jdd match nous est
venu daniel filipacchi après hachette et
ça a été la même chose et donc j'ai
poursuivi cette fidélité à l'héritage de
2 2 jean luc lagardère
[Musique]